hi everyone um thank you for sticking
around to the last talk here my name is
Strang um and this is me two years ago
fresh out of Academia pre- pregancy um I
this was the day before I started my job
at brist May squib very excited as you
can
see now like with many new jobs my first
weeks were filled with training and
orientations and getting to know my new
co-workers familiarizing myself with
everything else in the organization
which left me feel like this a few weeks
later I still remember the moment when I
first learned to ski and I felt like it
started get a hang of it I felt
confident I'm on nicely groomed Trail I
can turn my weight's forward feeling
very good but then comes a powder day
now if you ski you know what happens
everything falls apart I am no longer in
control I cannot turn there was way too
much powder and I I was scared I felt
like I wasn't good enough and there was
still a lot more to learn well at BMS I
started my hands on like a few different
bigger projects and I had very little
contacts on them most of my time was
spend and digging around for essentially
non-existent
documentation and any progress at that
point felt extremely
incremental but in retrospect I think
the onboarding process can be structured
quite in a straightforward way with
three items on the
checklist you want to understand the
company systems where the servers are
and everything you want to build
relationships with your new colleagues
and I do think that you also want to
develop some new skills um and start to
contribute so like Lydia's journey of
learning data science how she structured
that around uh
r4ds my argument today is that by
structuring the onboarding process
around a small doable problem you'll be
able to check off all of these items on
your
list lucky for me this problem came very
quickly after I joined so we were in a
bigger
brainstorming meeting when my manager
Ian sent this message on teams do we
have a BMS color theme would be very
useful so I thought well I can continue
to get frustrated and struggle with
these two bigger projects or I can take
on a new one that is more fun and
hopefully more
doable and today I'm here to tell you um
the story what I learned in building
this package that I later named BMS Dash
and how we rewarding it felt um and the
environment the very engaging and
productive environment that it
created so first the
questions before you build anything you
always faed with tons of questions mine
was were where can I find the color
templates what about the
fonts what are
these Warf 2 and ttf files I've never
seen them before how does shiny work I
never built a shiny app before although
many of people in my team have um and
then once I get something then where do
I host the ab and I've heard about this
BS lib package that's very good for
theming will it be
useful and is there a way to circumvent
the manual installation of fonts on the
user's computer and finally once I have
this package together how do I
distribute at first I was trying to you
know work through all these cions by
myself doing my own research and
everything but I soon realized that
these questions were a great excuse to
talk to my incredible new colleagues so
let me introduce you to my co-author of
BMF Dash Leslie Clara Lon and
Ian with these individuals have been
incredibly welcoming and supporting me
supporting to me from the beginning uh
when I first joined they would answer
every single question they had from oh
where's you know The Branding
information store or um how do I ignore
this file when I deploy my shiny
app and also these questions so instead
of in a one-on ones instead of going
through these small talks and ask about
you know oh how was your day what' you
do during the weekends I have these real
questions that they can answer and they
were great starting points for um our
conversations I was surprised to learn
that at BMS we actually use a lot of
posit products before it was called
posit team
so for BMS Dash I would develop the
package on workbench distribute some of
the um deploy some of the example shiny
apps and um Flex dashboards and
notebooks on connect and then finally
once I have the me the package I could
uh distribute it on I could put it on
package manager so that other people in
my team and and the company can download
and use
it I also learned about the J ticket
system pages and how to set proxy when
I'm on VPN so that I can download the r
packages from
crayon because somehow BMS block that
what new art skills have I
learned I learned that BS lib is magical
um I don't know if many of you here had
used it but um it's great for shiny and
especially in my case on the theming
side if you've seen oh BS stands for boo
strap if you You' used this function BS
theme preview what it would do is spin
up an example uh dashboard for you in
here you can choose what theme you like
the colors the fonts and once you've
done with all of that all you need to do
is close the app and what BS lib would
give you is um this snippet of code that
you can basically copy and paste into
your theme argument in your shiny
function so incredibly helpful if you
haven't checked it out um I highly
recommend you do so so that's basically
what I did I just WRA it around function
I called BMS light and then put those
color hex codes into my default argument
and then call BS theme in my
function what about the dot dot dots so
the rest of this function was to do
fonts um initially it was really hard to
kind of figure out all these font things
and the user would have to install the
font and load it into R
manually what I did was digging around
the BS lib GitHub issues and found this
really nice issue and I said it's really
nice because the poster had created an
excellent reproducible example where I
found this one line that was helpful in
my case this they said oh this line
borrows the fund from BS lib so then I
learned that oh I just need to put these
wolf 2 fund files that I found earlier
in the branding information into my inst
directory in the package and then use
this function add resource path in um my
package so that's what I did put it into
unload and finally another tibit here is
that you have to use CIS font the
package to add the font um into in into
your environment so in this case the
font that we have is BMS
Humanity all right so so with all of
that together now all the user have to
do is to change theme equals BMS light
and then you would get an app that looks
something like this you would have the
BMS signature passion purple and also
our BMS uh Humanity font and I can
capture the entire uh screenshot here um
for obvious reasons but hopefully you
can have a feel of what it looks
like I also added a few different
functions for um GG plot theming so for
example this is a this is an example
plot using the default theme but once
you add scale fill BMS and theme BMS it
would change the color to use our own
colors the BMS colors and then using the
humanity font
again I learned so this function is show
BMS colors I find it incredibly helpful
I sort of stole this from my friend Jake
Riley at the Children Hospital of
Philadelphia when I saw his talk um um
but yeah just a great he he has done
something uh internal package for for
chap as well um but I think this is a
great way to show especially with the
new our studio IDE you can see all the
colors and everything um so that the
user can you know kind of pick which
colors they want and they don't have to
go dig deep into any documentation for
you know oh what what colors um should I
use if I want this to be kind of looking
like BMS
brand okay one last tip on BS l
um so with all of that your DD T table
if you use it in your app which we do a
lot in in our um organization it may
still have this default blue when you
select a row and if you like me that's
really annoying like this blue in the
middle of all the purple so um to change
this color however you can use BS ad
rules to add a little bit more sass into
your app um so this just speaks to kind
of how customizable BS lib is
is and finally just a warning is to
watch out for different bootstrap
versions so make sure to kind of you
know try to pass through that version
argument because you may have a
different um shiny app and different uh
with different versions so if if the
user wants to use a different version
they can do
so all right so I'm now happy um I think
all of my skills have kind of improved a
little bit and in R but also some of my
new relationships I've gotten a handle
of um gotten some understanding of the
company's internal systems there was
still a lot more to learn but I I was
happy to to to know that the you know
the package was used right away and it's
still being heavily used today very
exciting to see you know any app any new
app that comes out that have this you
know BMS Dash
theme um I'm a huge fan of packages
because of all of these advantages that
it gives you you can read more on um uh
about you know advantages of an internal
package packages in this amazing blog
post by Emily reader some of the ideas
for um creating like startup packages um
if you're a new hire is to car a package
to connect to databases or perform some
simple imputation missing values of of
imputation of missing values or um
common visualizations or data
aggregations but it doesn't have to be a
package um if you're a new hire you can
just add more to the documentation or if
the documentation doesn't
exist create was some um put it in the
notebook deploy it on connect make it
visible for other people to use you can
create setup guide how to set up your vs
code to work with R in this ec2 instance
um or you can make Ben benchmarks so
this is an example notebook um written
in Coro by um a recent hire in our team
Jonathan Chang and as you you can see it
uses BMS Dash and actually it's not just
BMS Dash but BMS dash for CTO which my
colleague Jimmy here um made as as an
extension to BMS Dash um and so yeah
just you know by kind of working through
this I think he Jonathan put this
together maybe in less than a week he
learned CTO he learned connect and kind
of how to deploy all of this document um
and by the way he's a python programmer
but we love python the Ms to and in this
particular instance he were trying to
compare um the the speed in data
wrangling in um pandas poers and modern
so all that is to say you know I I think
focusing on a small problem is really
really um
valuable the success of BMS Dash um I
think it's not the end of the story here
I like to think that it's the start of a
culture of knowledge sharing in our team
and in an Beyond in the department as
well so you know we have BMS Dash I
eventually pull some of the theming for
G blot out to a different package I
called BMS pal we have potent for do
response um analyses so now scientists
don't have to kind of copy and Co copy
code here and paste it there we have all
things BMS which is actually not a
package but something I started writing
down um you know how to request access
to this particular server and then many
other
uh have contributed to it so including
my summer intern last year so very
excited about that um Jimmy also started
BMS connues which is the package to
track user uh stats on our deployed
documents okay so my call to action for
you today is that please be welcoming if
you have a new hire on your team now or
soon please invite them to contribute to
your existing project um using the
hashtag good first issue is a really
good idea to do so so they know where to
look be kind and flexible and patient
you know they knew they still have a lot
to learn and um so don't make them you
know contribute to something so big and
and you know expect results right away
if they contribute to your P packages um
give braavos give authorships so that we
can all build
together and don't get me wrong I think
everyone on the slope will have to fall
once in a while in order to learn um but
my hope is that together we can help
each other fall a little bit more
gracefully thank
[Applause]
you all right thank you Trang um so
again we are taking questions on slido
so you've done a wonderful job of
walking us through sort of that process
I'm wondering if you got to go back and
do that again what might you adjust or
do
differently um that's a great question I
think maybe just talking to more people
and don't afraid of get networking like
Lydia said um yeah because it was you
know when you started you feel like
everything is so new and um you don't
know where things are and so it took me
a long time to kind of figure out all
this information and and um but yeah I
think your co workers are there to
support you so um just get
talking fantastic let's thank Lydia
again thank all of our
speakers